MARKUS KLUTE: Hello.
Welcome back to 8.701.
In this lecture,
this little video,
we're going to look
at reactions and how
they relate to cross-sections.
So we start or
continue the discussion
of how we can relate
experimentally
measured determined properties
to the forces involved.
The last lecture, we looked
at decay rates and the rates
of unstable particles.
This time, we're going to look
at the reaction rates expressed
as cross-sections.
We can start doing this by
looking at this simplified
picture.
So the reaction rate
is related to the rate
of the beam, so how many
particles per second
are available for the
interactions times the number
density of the
particle in the target.
So you have your target here.
And clearly, the number of
reactions depend on how dense
your target is, the thickness--
so you go along how the thicker
the material the target is, the
more likely it is for reactions
to occur--
and then by the actual physics--
by the likelihood of
a collision to occur.
And this likelihood is
called a cross-section.
And we can think about
this cross-section
as a geometrical area.
All right?
So let's look at this
a little bit more.
We can stay with a
very classical model,
a model in which we have
two billiard balls--
and light one, a small
one, with radius r1,
and a larger one
with the radius r2.
Clearly, a collision occurs
when the impact parameter
b here between those
two billiard balls
is smaller than the
sum of the radii.
OK?
So now we can analyze this
reaction a little bit more
and look at angular
distributions.
We find that the cross-section
differential distribution
is given as a function
of sine theta.
We can also express this using
the azimuth or as a solid angle
here.
As a reminder, the
solid angle theta
is equal to sine
theta d theta d phi.
All right?
So for this specific
problem here,
we talk about an
isotropic reaction,
because by definition the
cross-section per solid angle
is independent of theta and phi.
The mapping between sine theta
and theta is not trivial.
That's why you see this
shape of the distribution.
Yeah.
But the d sigma
d cosine theta is
[INAUDIBLE] if you look at this
as a function of cosine theta.
All right.
So this is just a
classical picture
of what we're going to
do later in the class.
It's using quantum field
theory or Feynman rules
in order to calculate
cross-sections, or the decay
rates.
But this classical
picture is really
something I would like
you to keep in mind--
the idea of the likelihood
of the collision to occur
is in units of an
area and can be
seen as a geometrical
cross-section is kind of a very
nice picture to keep in mind.
And it also helps estimating
orders of magnitude of rates
of collisions to occur.